hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 14 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it they did so many comic book things so
let's go after last week's episode the
teaser for this made it seem like it was
gonna be relatively calm at the calm
before the storm but they went comic
books so fast that I just started
screaming for the last 15 minutes of the
episode starting with top 10 WTF I'll
explain the comic book Easter eggs as we
go along
number 10 Rosita is sleeping with
Spencer to get over Abraham and how
funny is his reaction to her I'm trying
to make food why don't why don't we have
dinner what are we doing where's this
relationship going looking back now it's
actually a bit misleading because it
makes you think that the episode was
gonna be all awkward humor because they
move into a number 9 WTF Denise wants to
go on a supply run but Daryl and Rosita
are having none of it we're not
babysitting you number 8 WTF Denise
explains her past more awkward comedy
I'm actually pretty good with a stick
Daryl you're messing up the gear box
you're grinding the gears her parents
were alcoholics and she had a twin
brother named Dennis who died who
actually sounds a lot like Merle yeah it
sounds like we had the same brother
number 7 WTF Eugene wants to manufacture
bullets near the safe zone this is
actually a huge deal it's gonna help
them a lot the way he explained it is is
they'll just recycle the casings it's
the innards that they'll be making we
need to find us a [ __ ] tunnel ed
speaking of which enter number 6 W yeah
Eugene vs. lead Walker no no no let me
do this I got this strike one strike two
strike three that whole speech about
cutting his hair learning to adapt
tabletop RPG style I love the way he
explained it it's like a tabletop RPG
you learn to adapt to the environment
Eugene was pissed at Abraham for
seemingly taking away his agency no I
got to do this he's trying to prove to
himself that he's capable of adapting
it's not an ego thing and it's the same
deal with Denis I'm a smart person I'm
not making this up as I go along Denis
and Eugene had this real nice mirror arc
where they're both trying to prove that
they're capable of surviving number 5
WTF the Edison store Denis goes to
investigate the trapped Walker just
trying to prove to herself that she's
brave finds the baby crib looks around
sees the Walker incapacitated but then
you get the slow reveal of the wall the
hush
and then you find out what happened to
that baby that was in the crib just a
little deep-fried baby walker that looks
like it might have turned before that
other Walker turn and look how
desiccated the corpses it looks way
further gone than normal Walker so they
both probably starved to death in there
but does the reveal of the baby Walker
in the deep-fryer was the greatest thing
ever most disgusting most amazing reveal
just because you're wondering where the
baby is as they're panning around the
room so double WTF for the reveal of the
baby in the way that they revealed the
baby but how great that that got her
talking about her brother and that was
the bonding point for Daryl like after
after you get past the craziness of a
baby in a deep fryer they're able to
bond on their really angry brothers the
number four WTF Denise gets her soda now
this is the soda that she was trying to
get from the earlier episode she asked
Daryl she asked him to get a soda so
that she could give it to Tara because
that's all Tara wanted it was just meant
to be this really nice gift for someone
that she loved she has that exact same
Eugene moment where she's wrestling with
the Walker can't quite kill it tells
them to back the F up I got this kills
it and as a reward for her victory she
gets that soda she has this amazing
speech about personal agency being brave
being inspired by Rosita and then BOOM
number three WTF mega comic book moment
she gets killed with an arrow through
the eye just like Abraham in the comics
so for those of you that think that
Abraham is gonna die this season he's
gonna have to die a different way now
because they already took that comic
book moment from him but the way they
pulled this off is actually one of my
favorite types of deaths in shows like
this shows that do big WTF deaths where
you have this big impassioned speech
this big moment of victory and then BOOM
the balloon pops like the person's head
explodes they die in some crazy WTF way
usually as a giant exploding body but
you kind of laugh and then you feel bad
about laughing because you loved Anish
you're like oh my god she was so amazing
in this episode I can't believe they
killed her so you scream from excitement
and horror at the same time and it turns
out Dwight shot Denise with Darryl's
crossbow making it that much worse we
haven't seen Dwight since he stole the
crossbow and Gerald's motorcycle now he
got both back but it's so much worse
that it had to happen with the iconic
crossbow thank God number two WTF Eugene
totally bites his dick off now he
bid in through the pants so it might not
have been completely up that he
basically crushed everything south of
the Equator so be comforted by the fact
that his dick is never going to work
again if negan heard about that yeah
he'd be mad because of what the
survivors did but he would probably
laugh at Dwight himself seriously dude
you just got your dick bit off and on to
number one WTF Carol bails on the safe
zone I can't love anyone because I can't
kill for anyone where's she going we
learned in the teaser the deals gonna go
after her I don't think that we've seen
the last of her she'll probably show up
in the finale hopefully she makes it to
season 7 but she's on one of those Rick
flip flops you know we're like an
earlier seasons Rick's a little more
hardcore then he goes kind of emo then
we get to season four like the end of
season 4 and he goes hardcore again
beard Rick we go through porch dick so
Rick Rick has come full circle he's
badass Rick again maybe that'll happen
with Carol too otherwise I think she's
done for the apocalypse does not abide
pacifists even Morgan is building a
prison in the way they ended the episode
- with the creak of the porch swing and
the camera just zooming up on him just
makes you feel like he is going to be
forced to kill again to break that rule
that he made for himself so let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
moment from the episode was it Denice
being killed Abraham style from the
comics was a Eugene biting Dwight's dick
off I feel like it's actually is really
hard to pick because they're two of the
best deaths this season it's gonna be
really hard to top but remember we have
negan we have Lucille we'll probably see
something happen with that in the finale
but we actually just learned that
episode 16 the finale will be a full 90
minutes that's actually pretty typical
usually the finales are longer so next
week new episode be sure to subscribe to
get it and then the week after that will
be the finale while you guys wait for my
next video to post if you haven't seen
Shane from Walking Dead as The Punisher
in daredevil you can click here for my
first daredevil Easter egg video and you
can click here for my Game of Thrones
Season 6 Stannis video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight